hi there as is usually the case this
week's episode of ask mr. wonderful was
inspired from a question this one from
Zoe really intriguing loved that name by
the way
Zoe writes I watched your ask mr.
wonderful episode when you explained how
you made your first million I like the
story but it seems to me you surrounded
yourself with a lot of successful people
that helped along the way I just
graduated college and I am contemplating
my next move but after watching that I
know I need to work for myself too
so I have to start my own business my
question is this what are the
characteristics of successful people I'd
like to know and maybe adopt these
myself what I like about your question
is you basically are talking about
self-betterment you're you're trying to
learn from the characteristics of people
that have proven themselves to be
successful I think that's fantastic
but I would also say that it's important
to think when you're starting a business
if you're going to take that
entrepreneurial route that you need to
build a team most successful companies
are aggregations of teams where one
person's skill set augments the others
in other words what I've learned and you
know you a lot of people think one
person can do it all you can't you
generally people have something they're
really really good at and they also have
a huge deficit and in my case I love
sales and marketing but I hate logistics
I hate making widgets but I can't have a
business if I don't make widgets so I
had to find a great widget guy and that
kind of thing and as it turned out it
was a woman and so at the end of the day
you need a partner that can that can can
build and that team and so I would
highly recommend if you're gonna start a
business you want to find somebody that
you really like in terms of their skill
set not that a friend of your someone
whose skill sets fantastic so I'm gonna
walk you through what I think really
matter you know about what these let's
call it the five things of
successful people if you if you go look
at any successful entrepreneur even a
politician or a preacher or a soldier
whatever what makes them successful
number one on the hit parade ambition
the desire to go somewhere
the myopic focus that there's something
you're here for a reason and you want to
get that done whatever that is for you
it's never work when you're pursuing
your ambition it's just it's just who
you are it's you it's your soul it's
your being and I think that's what makes
great entrepreneurs or great leaders
they they want to get up in the morning
they want to do what they you know what
their ambition is telling they have to
do ambition is a drive it's a vision
it's a drive it sounds like you might
have that Zoe which should be very
interesting number two and this kind of
is a little intuitive if you think about
it you have to care about yourself you
have to you have to have self-esteem you
have to believe in yourself even if
others around you don't even if they
doubt you even if they think that that
you're wrong you can't have that feeling
about yourself you have to have your own
perception that you are right and I'm
not saying but you know belligerent but
that you are worth every ounce of your
being and that you respect yourself that
way now it doesn't mean you can't listen
to other ideas but you have to have a
vision a direction if you don't know
where you're going Zoe no one will ever
follow you there I've said that
countless times and it remains true
today as it will a thousand years from
now people want to follow those that
understand the road the direction and
and you have to have that you know let
me be trite about it the kind of food
you you eat the exercise you know how
you look how you how you feel about
yourself how you dress how you present
yourself in the last few years I've
started to say to myself well gee you
know maybe I shouldn't when I'm walking
outside should have some sunblock on
that that sounds that's crazy no but I I
want to feel good about myself
so I'm using you know a shout out to my
sponsor this week T's Handley I use
their products because they don't have a
lot of perfume they have zero perfume in
them I don't like that smell and I like
the
we talk about what what it takes to be
successful taking care of yourself and
looking good is important and I care
about that tshh Hanley is a skin care
program but it's not complicated the
stuff isn't overly perfumey I don't like
that if I'm gonna spend some time
outdoors like I am today and I just
finished shaving I got to protect my
skin I don't want to get fried and I got
you know the dome of desire I've got to
cover that up because that can get burnt
really easily so I use the am from teach
Hanley because it's 20 SPF so sun
protection and a moisturizer you just
apply it really easily it doesn't smell
you know I want to look good forever if
you know what I mean I don't want to get
too wrinkly and you don't want a lot of
sunburn for that so that feels great
so look try these products I use them
the soaps fantastic the scrubs and all
that I mean the whole package ships to
you it's really easy it's a subscription
service look what can I say I like it
they got a great deal for my followers
so click on the link try them and yeah
good and I like it because that when I
finished shaving and I put on whatever
I'm putting on I feel I'm ready to go
present myself sounds corny you wouldn't
believe how important that is
particularly if you're going to stand up
or go in front of a lot of people you
want to feel good about yourself number
three then there's no real order to
these in terms of weight although I
would say ambition is always gonna be
the top of the list but a willingness to
learn and listen you can't believe how
many people can't shut up and listen I
learned that from one of my women CEOs
years ago she told me Kevin you seem to
spend 66 percent of your day talking and
only 33 and 1/3 percent you know
listening reverse change because you'll
learn a lot more they'll become far more
effective you just shut your mouth and
listen to what's going on around you and
she was right and today I really try and
balance that out 2/3 listening you know
one-third talking so the willingness to
learn comes from the desire to just
absorb information
and it's really important with that
comes something that is extremely hard
for entrepreneurs to do have patience
that's number four you've got to have
patience you have to hold back yet you
have to wait and see what happens you
have to let things develop
you can't just jam everything it doesn't
work that way you learn that through
experience and it's so important that
you understand you must be patient with
people you must be patient with plans I
mean you must be patient with you know
everything you you can't get what you
want right away it just doesn't work
that way people that are patient are
incredibly effective because in the long
run they get stuff done you have to kind
of sit back and assess things that's
what patience is it's an assessment of
your of your situation and I want to
tell you something that is really
important it's number five you are going
to fail in life everybody does something
you want you can't achieve you fail you
must be able to start again you must
learn from the mistake and it sounds so
obvious but you can't believe how many
people say oh I tried it it didn't work
and I just never pursued another
opportunity again great leaders great
entrepreneurs great people learn from
their mistakes but they don't let it get
them down like great great great
successful people are always saying it
was a horrific outcome really big
mistake lost you know 100 million
dollars if you're CEO or something it
was really bad but I realized the
mistake I made and I started again and
that kind of goes with the idea that you
must be patient to be successful if
you're an entrepreneur you only need one
great idea that takes you from being an
operator to an investor and that's
solving someone's problem in the world
and doing it a millions of times over
that's what how great companies are
created but along the way you are going
to have to use all five of these
elements to keep you moving forward so
let's summarize again it was ambition
ambition is the driver it's the engine
it's the machine that pushes you forward
self care
to feel good about yourself do whatever
it takes to put you as being a fan of
you like making sure that you do not you
must appreciate yourself that's very
important number three you've got to
have a willingness to learn and that
means shutting up and lit and listening
for you have to have patience and five
very important the ability to fail and
start again I guarantee you Zoe that you
will find all five of these in any
successful person you meet if you want
to take on any of these attributes it
will be a good thing for you I'm gonna
share a little trick with you in all
viewers
you see these pencils here on my desk
I've got these all over the place I got
probably thousands of these and I have
this this is the lowest tech thing
you've ever seen sticking out during the
day here's one I just this morning I
write down things I have to get done I
know it's low-tech there's all kinds of
software can do this for you I don't
care
I like pulling a pencil and simply
writing down oh yeah I got to get that
thing done and just making that note I
learned this from a very successful
person years and years ago my mother and
this note just sits here all day and at
night if I haven't finished and usually
there's three or four I haven't done I
look at it and say okay tomorrow I will
get this done before anything else
before you know I go online before I
read anything you know I go watch
television before I make any phone calls
or texts or anything I'm gonna get this
thing done and I stick it on the mirror
on the right hand side number one record
bass line four track 15 all right so I
found a piece of music that I recorded
back in 89 I'm working on a documentary
about watch styles which I think you're
gonna find interesting when I finally
get it finished but it needs the music
so the editors can work with the beat of
the music and this thing I record in 89
does not have any bass and I didn't play
bass back then now I do so I'm gonna go
back in the studio and lay down the bass
track for track
fifteen
[Music]
number two we concil
foreign currency i have investments over
in europe and each month i reconcile to
the currency to figure out how much of
the performance was gained or lost by
the change in the currency rates so i
want to do that this morning it's
important to get that done for last
month because you know if you don't have
that information you can't make moves
and number three
tape questions four and five for tax
hive tax hive is a new business i've got
involved in as an investor and also as a
spokesperson this is a company that
helps small business with their taxes
and payrolls very important in my
portfolio companies so i'm recording
some messages and four and five have to
be done today so i'm going to go in the
studio and record those great take
that's the one before i do anything else
today these three puppies are gonna get
done and that is how you get super
productive and you don't let anything
distract you you don't take a phone call
you know to emails it to anything you
get the things done that you made the
priorities the night before do it every
day try it it's fantastic look at this
low tech low tech you write it down a
piece of paper stick it on the mirror
come on it works
you can't believe how productive you
become with this simple trick it's
incredible it's absolutely amazing it
just drives you forward because you're
getting it done you're getting it done
you're getting it done and you're doing
it day after day after day I don't stop
on weekends it's every friggin day I do
it every single day and they can be all
kinds of different things but they're
things you got to get done could be
something you're doing with your second
significant other could be something
you're doing in arts it could be
something you're doing for business
doesn't matter it's one of those things
try that trick it's probably the best
thing you can learn from this week's
episode anyway so I love the question
thank you very much until next time
talking about characteristics of
successful people I've always believed
that you need to you need to mix yin and
yang together you know business is so
binary I've said this a million times
black and white you make money lose
money arts are chaos so if you're you
know whatever it is whether it's
photography whether it's music if you're
gonna pursue a business track you also
have to nourish your your other side
your artistic side and so that's why I
always tell people if you play something
stay with it or you know if you're a
photographer a paint or whatever do that
so recently you know my family's pretty
musical my sons are wicked guitarist and
he was learning the lead to Hotel
California which is a [ __ ] it's not
easy to play and you know it's it's
iconic and he was listening to the
record and working on and he said to me
dad I think this is Cape owed up two
frets and I said not another no no no no
they didn't use a cape on when they when
they laid down Hotel California the capo
is the thing like this you clamp it
across your guitar frets and you can
play a hierarchy I said no way they're
not using a cape on this he said no I
think they are so we get in a bit of an
argument and then I remember it I just
got back from shooting star chart a
couple of seasons ago
and I'd love to hang out at this
restaurant called Craig's and I think
Joe Walsh wants a piece of it or
something but anyways he was sitting
there so I just went over and said hi
were talking about shark tank and and it
was fun and I thought to myself why
don't I just text Joe Walsh and get this
argument over with just in case he
answers me there's my text Joe kevin
o'leary here my 20 year old son Trevor
who is now an amazing guitarist is
learning Hotel California on a
six-string
with a capo I told him that the song is
not played with the capo sorry to bug
you but who's right I'm thinking the
guys never gonna respond to me but Joe
Walsh is a nice guy anyway seconds later
here he comes back you're both right
Don Felder's opening of the song the
descending line was done on a capo 12
string to voice it higher all the guitar
work except that was done on non cabled
standard tuning six-string electric s--
hope that helps best joke
I love that it really helps so we all
got to get there we did Hotel California
and yeah I'm using a capo basically
we're both dried but Trevor was right
about you know it was being voiced
higher listened to his lead on it he
this is one of the first takes he ever
did it's fantastic the guy's good
[Music]
you
[Music]